dans la volonté d'enquêter sur cette
gestion le point de départ c'est un mais
mais mais mais pourquoi créton autant de
structures pourquoi investis sont autant
de ressources intellectuelles financière
pourquoi traitons des plans des
procédures d'urgence si ce n'est pour ne
pas les activés pour ne pas les
mobiliser au moment où s'écrivent se
réalise en danger donc ça a été vraiment
notre point de départ
effectivement le conseil scientifique
est une structure ad-hoc qu'il est prévu
par aucun plan aucune loi qui va
d'ailleurs être rétroactivement
officialisé avec la loi d'urgence
sanitaire et à sa suite va vont être
créé toute une série de au conseil de
comité alors on va voir le caire on va
avoir la mission castex pour le
déconfinement va voir la mission lizurey
pour l'évaluation de la coordination
interministérielle toutes sortes de
structures vont être mobilisés et crée
alors comment on a voulu interpréter ça
on l'a interprété comme on vous l'a dit
tout à l'heure comme je voulais dit tout
à l'heure dans une volonté
d'autonomisation puis le deuxième point
c'est celui que vous soulignez c'est que
y'a aussi c'est un geste technocratique
extrêmement traditionnel c'est qu'ils
ont ce qu'on considère que pour
améliorer la coordination et la
coopération entre acteurs qui est
absolument nécessaire en situation de
crise et il suffit de créer des
structures de coordination là où on a
des défauts une guerre entre le
ministère de l'intérieur et le ministère
de la santé pour l'appropriation de la
gestion crise comme c'est souvent le cas
eh bien on va créer une nouvelle
structure qui est censé leur permettre
une meilleure coopération donc on va
créer le centre la cellule atta mills
dalle de clichés pas ou souvenez mais au
mois de juin à peu près elle se
transforme en centre interministériel de
crise
donc ça c'est un geste technocratique un
canton quand on pense que ça va parce
coordonnées et ben on crée de nouvelles
institutions et on se donne jamais les
moyens de réfléchir à la façon dont
concrètement ces institutions peuvent
coopérer entre eux
[Musique]